[Música]
la Corte Suprema de Estados Unidos de
mayoría conservadora está cambiando al
país sus últimos fallos se eliminaron
por un lado la llamada acción afirmativa
que garantizaba acceso a la educación
superior a ciudadanías vulnerables por
su origen o sometidos al racismo
estructural del país por otro lado
limitaron la protección a la población
lgbtiq más esto apenas un año después de
anular el falloway que protegía el
aborto en todo el territorio para
conversar sobre este tema vamos a
conectar con Daisy báez quien es
analista y estratega demócrata además es
ex representante de estatales de la
Florida por el partido demócrata Y sí
bienvenida directo a América
Muchas gracias Buenos días y un placer
estar aquí con ustedes hoy Igualmente
Daisy para los grupos Defensores de
Derechos Humanos este fallo contra la
acción afirmativa en las universidades
vuelve a imponer dificultades
adicionales a jóvenes que ya enfrentan
todo tipo de vulnerabilidades por su
origen o por su color de piel usted Qué
consecuencia ve en esta decisión
muchísimas de hecho hemos mirado hacia
atrás y examinado alguna de las
iniciativas relacionadas con este tipo
de ideas por ejemplo en el caso de
California y otros nueve estados que ya
han pasado reglas donde no se permite
usar
la cuota digamos de la de La Raza en la
determinación de dar acceso a diferentes
universidades y programas educativos y
lo que hemos visto es muy claro cuando
estos programas no existen baja
excesivamente inmediatamente el número
de personas admitidas a estos programas
que son de casa negra o latina o grupos
minoritarios pero déjame decirte que yo
me siento un poquito como diríamos
calmada pero hemos visto que rápidamente
el departamento de educación y el
presidente han determinado que que va
hay opciones
administrativas que se pueden usar o que
se podrían usar para para tratar de
nivelar el campo lo que sabemos es que
un estudiante por ejemplo de raza blanca
de una familia holgada que ha tenido
acceso por ejemplo a tutores y buena
educación no está Al mismo nivel que un
estudiante de un de un área pobre donde
no ha tenido acceso al mismo tipo de
Educación Entonces cuando esas dos
personas están aplicando para acceso a
una universidad no es lo mismo y las
cuotas de raciales lo que hacían era
tratar de nivelar un poquito más ese ese
campo de que ambos tuvieran acceso
porque personas inteligentes porque
están dispuestos tienen motivación o sea
otros digamos otros aspectos que se
pueden usar en determinar el acceso a
las universidades sabemos muy bien que
cuando nuestros estudiantes nuestra
población se prepara es un producto
económico es algo que que mejora a
nuestros grupos que mejoran nuestras
comunidades porque cuando tenemos
personas que tienen
profesiones que van a ganar mejor sueldo
son mejores contribuyentes a la economía
Así que
algo mixto aquí en este caso en
particular vamos a recordarle a nuestros
lo que las personas que nos están viendo
que la Corte Suprema está compuesta de
nueve jueces de los cuales hoy en día
solo tres se consideran liberales eh los
otros cinco fueron puestos nombrados por
presidentes republicanos y se consideran
un poquito más digamos conservadores y
no no ha sido sorpresa muchas de estas
de estos fallos que hemos visto en las
últimas semanas de hecho podemos
discutir en muchos otros más no por
supuesto importancia me gustaría que que
abordáramos algunos de ellos pero antes
quería preguntarle detenerme un poco en
estos conceptos de discriminación no
podemos hablar por ejemplo de
discriminación de blancos porque
finalmente la decisión de la corte lo
que ASUME es que una población que ha
sido históricamente privilegiada se
declara víctima ahora de discriminación
y que esto atenta contra el principio de
que todos nacemos iguales y ciertamente
es que no todos nacemos iguales ese es
el problema aquí en el asunto no podemos
comparar que un estudiante caucásico y
con oportunidades y privilegio se sienta
discriminado frente a una cuota para
ampliar el acceso a otros grupos
Bueno definitivamente y eso me refería
anteriormente que el el plano no es no
está igual el estudiante caucásico como
tú refieres o blanco tiene si ya de por
sí ciertas ventajas oportunidades esto
es una nación donde donde damos
oportunidades a todo el mundo el estas
personas todavía tienen acceso a todos
estas centros educacionales tienen
acceso a todo lo mejor y y no es cómo te
puedo decir no se le está discriminando
de ninguna manera si tiene la educación
si tienen el los la preparación si
tienen el porcentaje la motivación
todavía pueden entrar a los programas
que quisieran pero las los grupos
minoritarios no tienen esas ventajas y
lo que estamos viendo que esta decisión
dice que no que no se debe considerar la
raza Porque todos somos iguales
deberíamos ser considerados considerados
Igualmente pero esa no es la realidad
eso no es lo que realmente pasa y para
somos una mejor nación una nación más
democrática cuando mayormente más
personas participan en los procesos y
por eso es que necesitamos que más
personas de grupos minoritarios más
personas de grupos de diferentes razas
participen en la economía bueno Usted
qué opina que va a pasar por ejemplo con
las admisiones por herencia que son
también muy tradicionales en las
universidades especialmente en las
grandes universidades de Estados Unidos
esto se revisará podría dar cabida para
que se abran discusiones en ese sentido
bueno la discusión se está viendo porque
estamos viendo ya de personas decir pero
vea acá no podemos considerar la raza
pero sí podemos considerar que tu papi
le dio dos millones de dólares esta
escuela
tú sabes hace unos años y por eso o tu
papá tu abuelo y tu bisabuelo fueron esa
escuela y por eso eso te da derecho a ti
a entrar esa universidad esos son muy
buenas preguntas y preguntas que se van
a estar debatiendo Próximamente lo que
sí sabemos es las personas que han
típicamente ido universidades lo que
dicen Ivy leads Harvard Stanford
todas esas prestigiosas centros de de
Educación sí tienen ventajas si tienen
ventajas porque sí se considera quién es
su familia Cuál ha sido su contribución
a la escuela Cuál es el historial de la
familia con esa con ese Centro Educativo
Entonces sí tienen ventaja vamos a ver
ahora entonces si sube un caso donde se
dice Bueno por esto no se debe
considerar ese caso no ha llegado
todavía pero creo que sí va a haber una
discusión sobre esto bien Además el
viernes de Izzi el supremo falló en
favor de un caso de un diseñador web que
ese cristiano en Colorado y que se
oponía a crear páginas para temas lgbtiq
más como matrimonios del mismo sexo y
demás y es lo que hizo fue alegar una
objeción religiosa la corte le dio la
razón porque esto es un golpe para la
ciudadanía diversa
Bueno fíjate que Honestamente Yo sí es
un golpe definitivamente pero lo que va
viene como dicen y mi opinión es que
bueno ahora
la eso le abre el campo la puerta a
cualquier persona decir bueno Yo no te
voy a dar servicio porque no me gusta
como te vistes o no me gusta
tu preferencia políticas o no me gusta
cualquier cosa o sea es un arma de doble
filo En mi opinión no estoy tan digamos
triste de que salió esta opinión porque
creo que al final del día no va a tener
los resultados que que los conservadores
están pensando están pensando que ahora
Bueno pues ahora vamos a mermar acceso a
los a las comunidades lgb o religiosas
de que tengan acceso a ciertas cosas
pero creo que va a ser todo lo contrario
esto le está dando una licencia a
cualquier comerciante de que puede
limitar a quien le da servicios Y bueno
pues ese es no según la corte el derecho
americano pero vamos a ver cómo eso
funciona cuando empiece a afectar a
otros grupos porque como siempre yo he
dicho como te lo hacen a ti se lo pueden
hacer a otras personas bueno Y aquí
tenemos que preguntarnos también pues
como esto parece una casa de naipes un
año después de que se anulara el fallo
de Robbie wave cuyo aniversario fue
recientemente y que reveló además un
panorama muy preocupante en términos de
salud pública y de derechos sexuales y
reproductivos para el país pero el
gobierno parece estar aún de manos
atadas a pesar de tener el control de
una de las cámaras Y pues el control de
la propia casa blanca usted como lo ve
Bueno
fíjate que yo pienso que cuando esta
orden pasó por la suprema corte ellos
piensan que es una victoria pero lo que
hemos visto desde entonces es muchas
elecciones a nivel de ciudades a nivel
del Condado a nivel Estatal que es
sorprendentemente fueron favorables para
los demócratas y lo que estamos viendo
Es una población de millones de personas
que ahora están
preocupadas por este tipo de decisiones
entonces tú estás piensas que estás
mermando los derechos de ciertos grupos
pero lo que estás es activando Esas
voces porque esas personas ahora dicen
pero bueno un momentito ahora el
gobierno que de los conservadores que
típicamente decían creemos en un
gobierno limitado que no es intrusivo en
la vida diaria de las personas estamos
viendo todo lo contrario estamos viendo
un gobierno conservador o o legislaturas
conservadoras que
dictar que tú puedes hacer con tu cuerpo
qué puedes leer Qué puedes hacer qué
puedes decir a quién le sirves A quién
no Y esos esas decisiones afectan
millones de personas y esa persona van a
votar el año que viene en las elecciones
primarias y en las elecciones generales
Así que es llamarlo Victoria eso está
por verse En mi opinión Bueno nos quedan
apenas unos segundos menos de un minuto
de entrevista Daisy Y esa era justamente
mi última pregunta cómo usted cree que
estas decisiones de un supremo
conservador van a afectar las elecciones
grandemente pero quiero no quiero dejar
este este comentario sin decirle para mí
la opinión más importante que pasó fue
la donde se en la corte se negó a
aceptar lo que le dicen los las
legislaturas independientes para mí si
hay algo que realmente era crucial para
nuestra democracia la democracia de esta
gran nación era ese fallo y fue en
nuestro favor básicamente dice que las
legislaturas estatales no pueden crear
legislación para para dirigir gobernar
administrar el voto nacional Si eso
hubiera si hubiera permitido hubiéramos
tenido ahora un caos de 50 listados
diferentes tratando de decir cómo yo voy
a correr las elecciones Y eso hubiera
sido realmente un una destrucción de la
Democracia americana las elecciones
continúan siendo una una cuestión
federal y a manos del gobierno Federal
Esto para mí de todas estas decisiones
creo que todas tienen tienen salidas
administrativas son cosas que se pueden
mejorar de otras maneras de hecho ya el
secretario de educación tiene planes
para Cómo ayudar a los estudiantes donde
en los créditos educativos sobre el
fallo donde no se el no se le puede
quitar la deuda según la Corte Suprema
todas estas otras cosas se pueden
mejorar esa de los del voto del manejo
de las elecciones no se hubiera podido
mejorar Así que yo en general Estoy
relativamente contenta de las de cómo ha
terminado esta sección de la Corte
Suprema Pues si le agradezco ya nos
quedamos sin tiempo ella es analista y
estratega demócrata además ex
representante Estatal de la Florida por
el partido demócrata Muchas gracias a
usted siempre a la orden
a nuestros televidentes sigan con
nosotros son pausa pero ya volvemos con
más de directo a América
[Música]